[Laughter]
or something
[Music]
you boasted openly of having six seven
Partners at once so is that righteous
there's no moral view from me
this is talk TV
good evening everyone I'm Joan Collins
and I am going to be completely
uncensored tonight only a fool only a
fool would think that was a legitimate
I do now yeah he can say it won't bleep
you I came to my senses
[Music]
and kicked it
that doesn't mean to me the guy's been
doing the same effing part for 35 years
I kind of only came on here because I
thought it would be kind of funny
um but I want to say you're don't bother
me anymore
how about if you do fight again you have
to give me a million pounds how about
that's a deal if I ask you what a woman
is what would you say a human being with
a boobs I have to start there I've been
trying to work out how much money you
must have made from American Pie if
everybody that knows that song came to
my shows I'd be selling out stadiums the
great piglet of politics has slipped and
squirmed through almost three disastrous
years of disorder and deceit what would
last longer this lettuce or Liz trust I
am resigning as leader of the
conservative party the letters won a man
must protect the woman and provide for
her so we need to make sure that she's
safe he needs a degree of authority no
problem but no but no you but people do
have a problem with it and that's the
world we're in now I'm over here
there's nobody in this country or the
world who hasn't lived the majority of
their lives under the reign of Queen
Elizabeth II this is how she wanted her
funeral to be and like everything the
Queen ever did it just showed Immaculate
taste uh unbelievable class and dignity
nothing and nobody has symbolized what
it means to be British better than Queen
Elizabeth
they're trying to force you out yes not
only the coach but the other two or
three guys there around the club that I
felt betrayed it was stated that Elvis
you know uh with um a racist he's never
been a racist when she said that Olivia
Wilde it's stungy didn't it thought the
marginalized were supposed to have the
voice and you've alluded to the fact
that you had Suicidal Thoughts at one
stage yeah I was closely going down the
garden where I used to have a point down
at the Garden with a little with a few
poles and I would I was that bad one day
do you believe you can win this war yeah
I don't only believe it I know it will
happen we will win we already showed the
whole world that he can kill us but to
conquer our people is impossible we have
another several billion years
it gave me if I look a bit sweaty and
moist the girlies apparently like it
that way
no problem with the tips no tips aren't
really involved in this
Stanley oh thank you peers interview
adjourned love you
turn the camera
president Trump well first of all how
are you very good we're doing well and
it's nice to be in Florida we're sort of
all over the place but a lot of times
spent in Florida what is life like as an
ex-president
well it's uh interesting it's beautiful
it's complex sometimes we have a lot of
endorsements going out and have gone out
we've done very well on endorsing
candidates that I think are very good
and they are very good and we've taken
people from who we're not going to win
and now they're winning big you're
talking like somebody who feels he has
unfinished business
well
we did a really good job we created an
economy that was incredible and now a
supply chain problems inflation problems
gasoline selling for five six seven
dollars think of it a gallon when I left
it was under two dollars and it was
largely under two dollars for a long
period of time 187
167 at one point and now it's five six
seven eight dollars depending on where
you are going up much higher and we have
a war that would have never happened if
I was president that war would have
never happened when the invasion started
you were quite praiseworthy of Vladimir
Putin you said he was a genius this was
no Savvy move he was going in as a
peacemaker no no that's the fake news's
version no tell me the truth when he
built up soldiers on the border I said
that's very smart brilliant move
because I thought he was negotiating
when he went in I said no longer a
brilliant move when you see the scenes
Mr President of maternity hospitals when
you see refugees being attacked as they
flee grandmothers children babies you
see the decimation of previously
prosperous cities living in a thriving
new democracy when you watch what's
happening I mean do you agree with my
assessment that Vladimir Putin is now an
evil genocidal monster yeah but I also
when I look at I do oh sure who wouldn't
what's happening is horrible when you
see Rockets going into apartment
buildings and there are plenty people in
those buildings you know they think
they're like the people who moved out
they didn't move they want to stay
because they think they're safe in their
Apartments far more people are dead than
you think when I see all the Death and
All That destruction and it's such a
stupid War because yet a country who was
working it was had problems lots of
problems but other other countries have
problems too it was such a horrible
waste to be doing it you see swings
outside you see playgrounds you see
hospitals it was a country
and the people were happy I guess a lot
of them were happy because they're
certainly fighting for it but I'll tell
you what I really think I said isn't it
a shame all those people are dead all
because of a rigged election because if
our election wasn't rigged you would
have had nobody dead when you said to
Putin don't invade Ukraine yeah what was
this well I told him what our response
was going to be and his response was
really I said really what did you say
your response and you know what if he
believed me good but if he believed me
only five percent he would have said
I'll never do it what did you say the
responsibility I'm not going to say that
I'm not going to say that but it was a
very strong response but did you
threaten I said for example the nuclear
capability I don't want to talk about
this he's been doing I don't want to
talk about that what I did say is
we're going to be very strongly
responding if you do that I also said to
president XI don't go into Taiwan
and there's going to be a very strong
response they both understood that they
both had the same reaction really
really I said really the thing that may
keep him out of Taiwan is how poorly
Russia is doing right and how vicious it
has to be how horrible it has to be
because China sees that and nobody wants
to see what's happening so what would
you do right now in Ukraine if you were
the President Putin uses the n-word I
call it the n-word he uses the n-word
the nuclear word all the time that's a
No-No you're not supposed to do that he
uses it on a daily basis and everybody's
so afraid so afraid so afraid and as
they're afraid he uses it more and more
that's why he's doing the kind of things
he's doing he's doing them because he
thinks nobody's going to ever attack us
because they're all stupid and they're
afraid to talk I totally agree with you
okay so would you do instead of excuse
me a little complicated sorry instead of
you know cow Towing instead of Biden
saying oh
he's got nuclear weapons he keeps saying
he's got no
we have better weapons that we have the
greatest submarine power in history what
would you say and do I would say we have
far more than you do far far more
powerful than you and you can't use that
word ever again you cannot use the
nuclear word ever again and if you do
we're going to have problems this is my
reading of what you've been saying is
that when you were talking to Putin when
you were president and he was talking
about potentially invading Ukraine that
you threatened him with your nuclear
capability I threatened him like he has
never been threatened before did you
threaten to use nuclear weapon I don't
want to say that I threatened him like
he has never been threatened before
what's your message for Putin now right
now if you could talk to him what would
you say to him I I would say it's a
shame what you've done
you're killing protect I think
potentially look you know if if these
people aren't smart and they're not our
leaders are not smart
if they're not smart you're going to end
up in a nuclear war this is just the
beginning this is the beginning and I've
been the best predictor of things ever
now it doesn't have to happen it
shouldn't happen but if our people
aren't smart you can end up in a nuclear
war what's your message he's watching
this interview and he will be look what
would you say I think they're dealing
with them incorrectly I think what
they're saying
it it's almost like they're speaking
with fear and they don't understand we
have
one weapon alone that would destroy
everything the things I'm not happy
about with the presidency I'll be
completely straight with you to your
face one of them is what happened on
January 6th which was a result of you
refusing to accept the result of the
election before you start this okay
Nancy Pelosi is in charge of security
she didn't do her job she's half in
charge of it so the Republicans excuse
me excuse me the mayor of D.C and Nancy
Pelosi are in charge actually
Republicans and the Democrats have 50
50. but she was actually cowering for
Terror in fear of a life that day
because there was a huge mob of people
if she who are attacking the the center
of Democracy in America if you talk the
talk and you're a great talker I've seen
that today if you taught the talk you
have to walk the walk in the context of
your claim about the fortune election
it's been 14 months and we've not seen
this hard evidence of the fraud that you
say happen the Press won't report it the
press this is like a communist country
it's all over the place we have
because I've watched this whole debate
right and you've been completely
unflagging in your refusal to accept
defeat you know why though you know why
because if our country doesn't have fair
and free elections and if our country
doesn't have borders we don't have a
country okay we have crooked corrupt
elections here's what I would say and
I've proven it and here's what I would
say to you I believe it was a free and
fair election and that you lost you
don't really believe that's my belief
well then you're a fool however then
you're a fool maybe I am a fool maybe
I'm the fool in this conversation and
you're a fool and you haven't studied it
okay I have studied it here's the big
question for you are you going to run
again well you know for reasons of
campaign finance and everything I'm not
allowed to say but let me just say this
I think a lot of people are going to be
very happy
I I love our country our country is
going to hell I think a lot of people
are going to be very happy you're going
to run I'm not going to say that but I
think people are going to be happy you
might even be happy if it's you against
Joe Biden if you win the Republican
nomination again and he runs again would
you beat him
uh I believe right now anybody I think
you could beat him right now look
there's quite being a fool they've done
a very poor job I don't have to say
anymore they've done a very very poor
job our country's a mess our country has
never been so disrespected our borders
have never been so open we've never had
in 44 years inflation like we have if
you run again and you win
which could well happen and I think
whoever the Republican candidate right
now it looks like the Democrats are
going to get shellacked in the midterms
it's quite likely whoever is a
republican nominee will end up being
president it could be you again
and for as many people who think that's
a great idea you'll know there are lots
of people who think that would be a
total nightmare far less far less I
think so yeah I think for for us I think
people are very angry at this country
they're very angry at our leadership
they wish they had their vote to do
again we didn't need their vote because
again we won the election by a
tremendous margin we won the election
actually very easily I haven't mentioned
that's it no yeah
[Music]
this was a 20-minute interview listen
this was a 20-minute interview uh I
think it's fine it's fine it's fantastic
in your opinion I wanted to end with the
hole in one I just haven't asked about
the Holy One do you want to go ahead
you recently got a hole in one playing
golf with Ernie else one of the great
golfers of the world what was that like
for you well it was great he's a great
guy great player one of the most
beautiful swings they say in the history
of golf and they're very powerful and I
made it with him and actually three
other tour Pros
and it was quite a thrill told me
through the shot
well I hit the ball it was hit well it
felt good the wind was blowing hard into
my face it was a five iron that went 181
yards and it went plank right into the
hole it landed on the green and one
bounce and it went Plank and
Ernie who's a low-key guy one of the
reasons he's susceptible The Big Easy
right
but Ernie and the other Pros started
jumping up and down in the air and they
said why are you guys so excited he says
because we don't see Hollow ones they
make I guess one every three tournaments
and then you have to be in the group so
it's very do you have one before I've
had seven this was a seven seven this
was my seventh which isn't that high a
number believe it or not if somebody
plays golf
I hear the record is 49 okay people you
buy a round of drinks in the bar often I
don't know but I would certainly have
been happy to drink I don't drink no
it's traditional you buy around that is
true that is true probably happened I
didn't check but probably happened
because I owned the club I'm sure it
happened congratulations all right thank
you very much thank you for a great
interview thank you very much appreciate
it
okay thank you okay let's go that was a
great interview yeah that's fine thank
you very much I really appreciate it
turn the camera off
so those who are who don't like you
there's people out there that don't like
you I know you said recently that you
were very popular and I think you seem
to be the most honest man in the world
I'm a very honest man was that true yeah
I think I'm a very honest man but for
those who don't like you much more
honest than you actually really yeah I'm
pretty honest because I don't think
you're real right yeah I think I'm a
much more honest person in most ways and
most reasons why am I not real but we're
not going to get into that let's finish
up the interview go ahead go ahead go
ahead most question was this what
message do you have to people who
can't think of anything worse than you
running again and will be distressed
about it would you come back with all
the experience you've had but being
president would you come back a
different person would you do things a
bit differently
do you believe you can win this war
yes no question you might not only
believe it I know it will happen
we will win he can occupy these towns
and Villages but all of them would be
destroyed because without ruining them
they will not be able to take those
places he's an inspirational leader and
the way the Ukrainian people have come
together in in these in these terrible
times I mean like you say we've never
seen a sovereign nation invaded by a
hostile foreign Nation since World War
II
Cristiano let me start just by asking
you why are you doing this interview
because I think it's the time to say
something
um
and because I like you it's simple as
that I don't say that in public here
how many times a day do you get told to
tell people to f off all the time like a
dozen times I was at the Scottish
Baptist last night and it was I couldn't
get away from people and of course as I
said before it's the best thing to tell
people yes because when you're fed up
with them you go you know you can say it
won't bleep you oh
don't bother me anymore just
you know what I'm not gonna watch what I
say sorry because I don't think you do
either really I think that both of us I
think have the self-confidence to say
you know what stuff this nonsense uh
yeah stuff the fun police is saying what
my great friend used to say uh because I
think it's just so what it does it
removes all the fun out of life it makes
life a very joyless kind of experience
isn't it I don't know what's going on in
the world everybody's upset for
something and no matter what you say can
please everybody but for me the only
person I'm interested in pleasing his
new wife and I'm struggling with that
most of the time
I I can't play like that my wife gets
mad when I'm playing she doesn't like my
sense of humor well your wife is
definitely thinking I'm gonna get
canceled or something
[Music]
you posted openly of adding six seven
Partners at once so is that righteous
I'm not taking him there's no moral view
from me
[Music]
well welcome first of all um you come
all the way from Romania to do this
interview correct what what do you hope
to achieve from this interview why are
you here it'd be interesting to have a
conversation with you you've certainly
been uh the subject of your own divided
opinions in the world uh there's a lot
of people who would say some of the
things you say are perhaps dangerous or
toxic so I thought you'd be a good
person to speak to about this subject I
didn't know much about you before this
year and then I suddenly became very
aware of you as the world did because as
I said earlier you you were the number
one subject searched on Google ahead of
Donald Trump I don't think it was even
possible why did you get suddenly so
popular stroke Infamous do you think I
exploded uh I certainly didn't do that
with magic I've been on the internet for
a very long time I think in the world we
live in now as the other side the other
side the people who disagree with me as
they get more and more tyrannical on
their censorships and their hate mobs
Etc as standard masculine practices are
deemed toxic I didn't put a magic spell
on everybody I managed to accumulate a
large amount of affinity with the male
populace Across the Western world
because I'm simply saying things that
many men believe think and feel when
I've gone over everything that's been at
the center of the debate about Andrew
Tate I come down with Joe Rogan in the
sense that there's a lot of stuff you
say I agree with you know I've got three
sons in their 20s it's not easy actually
being a young male in the modern world
um and I think a lot of the things that
you say about that uh can resonate with
them the problem comes with the I don't
know 10 20 or whatever of your output
which on the face of it appears to be
blatant misogyny and when you couple
that with your massive influence and
huge reach that is why the social media
companies have decided to effectively
cancel you I don't believe in
cancellation I don't believe in
censorship particularly that's why I've
invited you to come on the show
um but I do think a lot of the things
you've said are blatant misogyny do you
accept that so you made a very
interesting point there you just said on
the face of it appear to be blatantly
misogynistic I understand that on the
face of some of the long format content
I've made if you're going to take a few
seconds out of hours chop it up put it
all over social media accompany with my
massive Fame then things can absolutely
not really be taken out of context I do
not hate women in any regard I have no
negative relationship with women no
women have come forward saying I've hurt
them I've no criminal record for hurting
women there's no way I can be seen as to
face or the devil in regards to how men
treat women on on the planet I'm
absolutely not really the opposite I
believe in protecting and providing some
of the things you've said I just think
are blatantly well let's do let's do
them well let's hear them let's go
through something sure right do you
think women are the property of men no
the point why have you said they are
because I made a religious point I said
that when a man marries a woman the
woman's father walks him down the aisle
walks her down the aisle and hands her
way to the man traditionally that's what
it says in the Bible I'm a religious
person I believe in God I live in the
Muslim so you do think that the woman
becomes the men I think she takes his
last name you're straight talk I think
my sister is her husband's property do
you regret saying it like that I I
understand that with my newfound Fame
perhaps it could be phrased differently
however I still believe that a woman is
given to the man in marriage that's what
I believe yeah but not as property now
the property is the word that other
people use the question but as a an
equal partner in a loving Union that's
what marriage actually means it doesn't
mean that when you get married the woman
is given to you as a bit of Chapel
agreed so why say it but that's the way
the people ask me the question people
say to me they ask the question you
can't blame people for asking you
questions surely if you want to be
accountable for what you've said you've
got to own your responses don't blame
the question I own the response let me
ask you a question now and you say
something and then say well I should
blame you for I understand peers peers I
understand I believe the woman is given
to the man I believe she's given away by
the father I believe she belongs to the
man so you do belongs to fundamentally
right so fundamentally you do believe
that a woman becomes a man's property I
believe she belongs to the man in
marriage correct right
oh you see that to me is misogyny and
you're entitled to your opinion right
but do you want do you not understand
why people think it is misogyny I
understand why some people can be very
offended by what I say what they do is
they take a point like that and they
ignore all the other points I make the
other way right that's why that's why
I've repeatedly asked you about that
line to see if you've changed your
position but the reality is you haven't
it's not about changing positions I'm a
full-grown adult and I stick by the
things I say and I'm responsible for
them which by the way is fine do you
respect women absolutely why wouldn't I
do you think the 18 19 year old woman
are more attractive than 25 year old
woman I think there's Attractive people
uh that's that's a loaded question I
don't know it's not real is it I I can't
know why I'm asking you of course I do
but I can't sit here and so the benefit
of viewers who don't know why I'm asking
you said this in general this is also
one of the reasons men find youth
attractive you want to blow up the
internet or block the internet write a
thing now the reason 18 and 19 year olds
are more attractive than 25 year olds is
because they've been through less dick
people say oh you can't say that but yes
I can a 19 year old is more attractive
than 26 year old woman and I'll tell you
why because that 26 year old has talked
to more guys been to the club more times
been effed and dumped more times more
arguments More Mess more for me to clean
up that
is misogyny why because you are
encouraging a mindset about 25 year old
women that makes them sound out to be
infinitely less desirable than 18 19
year olds and having effectively been
having too much sex to be taken in a
more respectful way that would well
firstly even if that was the case that
wouldn't be misogyny but what did you
mean by what you said that's not
misogyny because it's not anti-women I'm
saying that an 18 or a 19 year old woman
would be more desired 25 year old woman
anti-25 year old women we can argue but
not misogyny that's no no no it's not
being anti-any woman at all is misogyny
not when I'm not what I'm saying that
women are beautiful and attractive at a
certain age and saying the ages are more
attractive than 24. other than ageist
perhaps but misogynistic absolutely but
you just accepted it was misogyny no I
didn't you said it was Monster Sergeant
I'm telling you no it's not so you don't
think if you're saying slightly hateful
things about it that's not slightly
hateful do you wish you hadn't said that
I understand how it's been misconstrued
I understand how it's been weaponized
against me do I regret it because it's
been weaponized and used against me well
that's slightly annoying did I that's
not why did I at the time mean what I
said and in the context of the
conversation which obviously you you're
not familiar with and the people at home
are not familiar with no I meant what I
said if a 25 year old woman was watching
this would you say I'm sorry for saying
that well I wouldn't want anyone to be
offended by anything I say but I say
things when I say things that offend and
this is the thing that's interesting
Pierce please let me finish are you
again you're leaving like a politician
but hang on you could say I'm
interrupting you do but you're answering
a different question to the one I asked
you so as an interviewer okay sure okay
okay you accept that that's except we
both got on okay so again my point is
simply if a 26 year old woman is
watching this and has heard those
comments would you just say to her look
I'm sorry I shouldn't have said that no
I won't I will say that I am sorry that
that offends you however there's a large
contingent of the world doesn't mean
you're sorry no I'm not sorry that's the
point I'm making I'm sorry if that
offends you however there's a large
contingent of the world that believed
that and I was mediating for a
conversation have you ever been in love
yeah how many times uh plenty I believe
in love between men and women I'm a real
love you know yeah I believe how many
times would you say enough I believe men
and women are a beautiful Union I think
we're slightly different but when we
work together we're the most powerful
force in the world how many women have
you loved I don't know Pierce a few give
me a bull Bob
ten twenty let's let's say you don't
forget how many people you've been in
love with let's say 10 I mean I've been
in love and I certainly believe that men
and women when they work together it's
the most beautiful force on the planet I
believe in family I believe in children
I believe in if you believe in family
and children and love yeah why are you
single I'm not single well you're not
married so I mean well if I was married
the last thing I would do is advertise
it to the feral Psychopaths on the
internet so that's what federal psych
about well like you call me friend
earlier can be debated peers you believe
in the concept of marriage completely
that's what we were talking about the
whole time what do you think we talked
about a man giving a woman away I
believe in marriage more than anybody I
believe in marriage and no please I
believe in marriage in the traditional
sense I believe a man has a duty to
stand up and be a real man I believe
that the problem with the world today
that we are facing is that not enough
men are sticking to the age-old ways of
masculinity I believe that me standing
up and saying a man must protect a woman
and provide for her so he needs to make
sure that she's safe he needs a degree
of authority I have no problem with no
but no you but people do have a problem
with it and that's not sorry and that's
the rule we're in now I'm over here but
I think what's interesting talking to
you is it seems to me like you have gone
on a bit of a journey of self-aware and
it's about the impact of some of the
stuff you said in the past and you have
said you wouldn't say it again in the
same way now you may not want to express
regret for that but it shows me that the
very least you have evolved to somebody
who recognize is that these can be quite
damaging in the way that you said them
completely as a professional and as an
adult it would be stupid for me to sit
here and say that now that I'm the most
famous man on the planet my words do not
have more impact than they did before
what do you believe about depression do
you believe depression is a real thing I
believe that feeling depressed is real I
don't believe depression as a clinical
disease is real no really correct you
don't believe people can be clinically
depressed I think PTSD is very real I've
unfortunately I have some friends who
suffer from that and I know that feeling
depressed is real I believe that the
number one power you have against these
things are trying to take control of
your own mind and affecting your own
life I believe that it's not healthy to
hand over all your power and believe
that depression is an outside disease
that you can't affect I know that when
I've had difficult periods in my life
and also many of my friends like I've
said suffered from PTSD and been through
terrible things I've lived a very
difficult life and I know people who
have that the things that made them feel
better is when they woke up and said you
know what I'm not going to allow this to
damage me anymore I'm going to take
responsibility I'm going to get up and
I'm going to fight this as hard as I can
and by the way on that I agree my
favorite speech is the Rocky Balboa okay
so then we agree no we didn't we don't
agree Pierce you don't hang on you've
got to let me sure interject when I
don't agree with you sure well I don't
agree with you is that there's no such
thing as clinical depression there
absolutely is well it's a proven
scientific medical reality there's a
different argument about have we gone a
bit too soft right in the schools and
all the rest of it absolutely yeah do I
think some people moan and whine too
much about their lot in life definitely
okay are we a victimhood society 100
okay is there such a thing as clinical
depression absolutely so and my argument
is that if you actually bracket
everybody who's not politically
depressed and doesn't have the genuine
medical condition then actually if
millions of people are deemed to have
depression the ones who really need the
help don't get it well that's my point
well that can that that I would agree
with you're right I think it's certainly
overused terms there is such a thing
called depression no I don't and that to
me is a damaging view okay well let me
explain why if someone comes to me and
says I'm clinically depressed or I feel
very very sad I would say the first
thing you need to do is stop accepting
the identity of a clinically depressed
person stop accepting you have no
control over this Andrew you're simply
wrong
if that's what you believe Pierce that's
what I believe I don't believe in things
that take power away there is not an
eminent doctor in the world would agree
with this I think you know more than
doctors I can't become clinically
depressed
why do you know because I don't believe
it
I can't be haunted by a ghost if I don't
believe in ghosts well it's not saying
I'm never going to die because I don't
believe in it it's ridiculous
so those who are who don't like you
there's people out there that don't like
you I know you said recently that you
were very popular and I think you said
to be the most honest man in the world
I'm a very honest man was that true yeah
I think I'm a very honest man but for
those who don't like you much more
honest than you actually really yeah I'm
pretty honest because I don't think
you're real right yeah I think I'm a
much more honest person in most ways and
most recently why am I not real but
we're not going to get into that let's
finish up the interview go ahead go
ahead go ahead my question was this what
message do you have to people who
can't think of anything worse than you
running again and will be distressed
about it would you come back with all
the experience you've had but being
president would you come back a
different person would you do things a
bit differently
do you believe you can win this war
yes no question you might not only
believe it I know it will happen
we will win he can occupy these towns
and Villages but all of them would be
destroyed because without ruining them
they will not be able to take those
places he's an inspirational leader and
the way the Ukrainian people have come
together in in these in these terrible
times I mean like you say we've never
seen a sovereign nation invaded by a
hostile foreign Nation since World War
II
Cristiano let me start just by asking
you why are you doing this interview
because I think it's the time
to say something
um
and because I like you as simple as that
I don't say that in public
how many times a day do you get told to
tell people to f off all the time like a
dozen times I was at the Scottish
Baptist last night and it was I couldn't
get away from people and of course as I
said before it's the best thing to tell
people yes because when you're fed up
with them you go up you know you can say
it won't bleep you oh
don't bother me anymore just
you know what I'm not gonna watch what I
say sorry because I don't think you do
either really I think that both of us I
think have the self-confidence to say
you know what stuff this nonsense uh
yeah stuff the fun police is saying what
my great friend used to say uh because I
think it's just so what it does it
removes all the fun out of life it makes
life a very joyless kind of experience
isn't it I don't know what's going on in
the world everybody's upset for
something and no matter what you say
can't please everybody but for me the
only person I'm interested in pleasing
his new wife and I'm struggling with
that most of the time
or something
[Music]
you posted openly of adding six seven
Partners at once so is that righteous
there's no moral view from me
this is talk TV
[Music]
I want to give you the time and the
platform to really explain yourself
because I think that sometimes sound
bites about people uh perhaps taken out
of context sometimes can create a very
distorted view of what a person really
thinks
um what do you think looking back over
the last few weeks in particular what do
you think have been the biggest
misconceptions about you
well I think there's a left agenda to
silence anyone that goes against the
agenda let's go back to uh Trump running
for office
back in 2015 everyone that was around me
in my industry in the entertainment
industry told me that my life would be
over I would be on the wrong side of
History I've even had threats to my life
for wearing the Trump hat and it it even
ended up in you know destroying my
family and also making it where I have
to raise my children differently because
I actually am
uh a person that's classified as black
you know I classify myself as Jew uh but
a person has classified that had been
given that title in America as black in
America that I'm supposed to stay in a
block of a vote you never heard the term
white vote so why is there a term black
vote how is that okay it sounds just as
racist as a black drinking fountain and
I'm my dad you know called me and said
you know the thing that the left
fear about yay or makes me the most
dangerous is I'm rich
and that's the point
Tupac told me back in the days you know
you had to get your money right and then
you go to war so I'm going to war you
know I don't I don't have I don't have
endless resources I only have like maybe
you know honestly only maybe 120 million
dollars in my account there's you know
one percent of the world are placed in
power and 99 of the world are the
audience so that one percent of the
world this idea of the United Nations
this is the world that needs to come
together this is the world that I mean
here's the obvious go-to Biden doesn't
listen to Elon Musk
the president of the United States does
not have meetings with Elon Musk that is
hey here come come come get me that's
[ __ ]
I know I'm not supposed to say that
Biden but that's [ __ ]
Biden and and I you know it's
um
and obviously because I've been deemed
with mental health all this I have the
right to use whatever words that I like
to use well that's interesting so
somebody ask another question well yeah
let me ask you on that so you just you
just said something very inflammatory
about President Biden it will as you
know offend a lot of people and it will
particularly offend people who work in
mental health who say you should not use
a word like [ __ ] but you say that
because you yourself have had mental
health issues that entitles you to use
that kind of word as an insult now I
would say that's an arguable Point I've
had my issue my issue is I've had mental
health allegations
what they had so many people to comment
on my white lives matter t-shirt there's
people who are saying right there in
Fashion Week when are you going home I'm
so afraid people thought I was going to
cancel myself I'm not going to cancel
myself I'm going to keep on delivering
what I feel because guess what it's very
split opinions by the way if I talk to a
black person that makes under a million
dollars a year they really are they
really relate to the George Floyd
comments and feel hurt that I would even
uh bring it up and question the approach
let me just pick you up on the two
things you've mentioned the first one is
what you said about George Floyd and the
the reality of that it's not a media
interpretation of how he died because
the Hennepin County chief medical
examiner concluded that Floyd died from
cardiopulmonary arrest his heart stopped
Complicated by the way the police
restrained him and compressed his neck
now he also said there were other
contributing conditions let me finish
there were other contributing conditions
narrowed arteries high blood pressure
and Fentanyl intoxication but although
these were significant conditions he
said and things that played a role in
the death they didn't directly cause the
death the cause of death was what that
policeman did with his name that person
well why would a coroner lie what makes
you believe that why would it Corona lie
because he could get paid to lie because
he could get paid delighted yeah I
watched it I watched it but the majority
of the press right but I watched it for
eight minutes but on the specific point
about how George Floyd died I don't
think it's in question about what
actually killed him it was that police
officer
well it is in question it isn't it is a
question I'm questioning it white person
what you're questioning is a coroner
report I say hey are do you do you have
friends that were killed by police
officers do you have friends that were
locked up do you have friends do you
have uh people aborting half your race
no so I am the black person with the
black experience that's worth 11 billion
dollars and is the most influential
person on the planet and I am
questioning it okay you and I have a
right to question absolutely you can't
tell me you can't tell me you can't tell
me with your accent that me as an
American Jew black person that I cannot
question that deaf and question the
means he had I was put on camera
la la la mean so let me finish okay I'm
not finished talking so we can't I
cannot I see because you distract my
thoughts and then you try to make me
look like a crazy person and you feel
you have the right to cut me off and
I've proven you you guys don't want it
with me this is like Terminator 20.
you've never seen this before let me ask
you yeah if I can about the allegations
that you have made anti-semitic comments
and in particular when you said on
Instagram I'm a bit sleepy tonight but
when I wake up I'm going Defcon 3 on
Jewish people now many people who are
Jewish found that deeply offensive they
wanted to know what what did you mean by
going Defcon 3 on Jewish people because
deathcon 3 as you know is a heightened
state of awareness for military action
so what did you mean by that well thank
you for allowing me to say what I meant
due to the fact that I was blocked by
Jewish people after I said that so it
wasn't actually allowed to say what I
was about to say but what I was going to
say is
I was going to talk about all of the
contracts
all of the missed dealings that I dealt
with as an Entertainer being that I'm an
Entertainer I've been wronged so many
times by Jewish businessmen maybe they
would feel how all my people have felt
maybe they would feel the pain of when a
black artist looks up and they've been
completely they've completely been raped
by five Jewish businessmen and there's
multiple accounts why does the first are
they Jewish have anything to do with
feel like that but why why would you say
it just so happens they are well okay
but I wouldn't why categorize them
according to their religious Faith their
ethnicity why would do that why can't
you just describe them as business
people that you've dealt with
that's fine but what you're doing by
saying Jewish people these constant
tiradesier against Jewish people
many people find it that sounds like you
have it I think it's a time what is the
tirade that was just that was a tweet it
was a tweet it's not just you asked me
to explain it and that have you felt my
pain yet you haven't felt my pain I've I
don't want to fight myself I know you
don't hold a counter la la la la la la
la you don't hold accountability to my
pain you're being a Karen I'm talking
about I'm talking about
pain I'm not a cow and I'm not going to
cancel you and I'm not going to uncens
you I'm simply going to challenge you on
what you're saying I think you don't
understand the pain that you've been
causing with some of these comments and
I think that one in particular I can
understand God God forbid God forbid one
comment could cause people to feel any
of the pain that my people have went
through for years even like the blacks
being ushered to the left during the
Civil Rights Movement no one is cared
okay
I don't know all right no one is can I
let me say I agree that the racism
against black people has been utterly
deplorable shameful unacceptable and
thank God the world is beginning to move
to a better place
people like you however however one form
of racism is in a better place
I'm not cutting you off I'm finishing my
sentence so you can respond wonderful
racism
racism it is racism when you say I'm
going down
that's racism no it's not I think racism
of racism is wrong any form of racism is
wrong I don't I I didn't say I didn't
say Defcon on anybody though you said
Defcon 3 on Jewish people specifically
Jewish people you didn't say any
particular Jewish person you said
basically all of them that is racism yay
I was in a position where I've been hurt
and this is the way I had the right to
express myself the point of this
interview is for you to question me and
then for me to answer and say okay even
though the same rules are not applied to
my people if a person with a gun or
drugs is pulled over and has four three
other people in the car they're all
going to jail I'm not going to apply
that to Jewish people for the sake of
this conversation isn't that what you
wanted but you know what you did you
tried the Civil Rights me you tried to
pull me back to a week ago there's been
plenty of Commerce conversations and
commentary since that but you want me to
go back to 19
let me jump in here's what I want you to
do I want you to okay so have we grown
have we have we have we grew this how we
grow here's how we grow I want you to
reflect have we grown I'm about how do
we grow I'm not in charge of my growth
United charging I'm about to okay like
this I'm about to suggest to you how you
may grow if you choose to grow this way
and you can you can ignore me you can
ignore me Pierce Pierce how much money
are you worth not as much as you sadly I
think you should say to the Jewish
people I'm sorry for the offensive
language I used in that tweet I wouldn't
do that again this is what I really
meant I think people would respect you
if you said that I don't know why you
can't just say that okay so I'm gonna
tell people when I would apologize for
the tweet this is what has to happen
first
I need all of the top Executives in
Hollywood I need the top Executives at
the MBA and at the NFL we'll we'll do
those two sports specifically and I want
the top Executives in music dealing with
publishing dealing with uh like Spotify
and apple music and uh Universal Music
and all the topics that uh let's do like
five topics X there and I want to look
at the top 10 earners in each one of
those fields contracts openly we want to
compare and contrast the contracts and
then once we open that conversation and
we need to do it on a platform live with
lawyers asking questions and we'll and
we'll have the top lawyers like a Johnny
Cochran Robert Kardashian level legal
team you know looking at all of these
contracts together after that moment
happens then I will say I'm sorry
okay if that's your position point of
view interview adjourned love you
so those who are who don't like you
there's people out there that don't like
you I know you said recently that you
were very popular and I think you said
you're the most honest man in the world
last week I'm a very honest man was that
true yeah I think I'm a very honest man
for those who don't like you much more
honest than you actually really yeah I'm
pretty honest because I don't think
you're real right yeah I think I'm a
much more honest person in most ways and
most recently why am I not real but
we're not going to get into that let's
finish up the interview go ahead go
ahead go ahead most question was this
what message do you have to people who
can't think of anything worse than you
running again and will be distressed
about it would you come back with all
the experience you've had of being
president would you come back a
different person would you do things a
bit differently
you believe you can win this war
yes no question you may not only believe
it I know it will happen
we will win you can occupy these towns
and Villages but all of them would be
destroyed because without ruining them
they will not be able to take those
places he's an inspirational leader and
the way the Ukrainian people have come
together in in these in these terrible
times I mean like you say we've never
seen a sovereign nation invaded
by a hostile foreign Nation since World
War II
Cristiano let me start just by asking
you why are you doing this interview
because I think it's the time to say
something
um
because I like you as simple as that I
don't say that in public how
how many times a day do you get told to
tell people to f off all the time like a
dozen times I was at the Scottish
Baptist last night and it was I couldn't
get away from you and of course as I
said before it's the best thing to tell
people yes because when you're fed up
with them you go you know you can say it
won't bleep you oh
don't bother me anymore just
I'm not gonna watch what I say sorry
because I don't think you do either
really I think that both of us I think
have the self-confidence to say you know
what stuff this nonsense uh yeah stuff
the fun police is saying warm my great
friend used to say uh because I think
it's just so what it does it removes all
the fun
it makes life a very joyous kind of
experience isn't it I don't know what's
going on in the world everybody's upset
for something and no matter what you say
can't please everybody but for me the
only person I'm interested in pleasing a
new wife and I'm struggling with that
most of the time
I I can't play like that because my wife
gets mad when I'm playing she doesn't
like my sense of humor well your wife
she's only thinking I'm gonna get
canceled or something
[Music]
you posted openly about him six seven
Partners at once so is that righteous
there's no moral view from me
this is talk TV
[Music]
yay thanks for sitting back down I'll
change the subject now I want to ask you
about your your family a lot of stuff
has been written about you and your
family a lot of it fueled by you by Kim
by others where are things now with your
family what is what is your relationship
like with Kim with your kids
uh
uh
Kim has
zionists media handlers
surrounding her all in and out her Hulu
TV show all in and out her her family
all in or out the house that I created
for my family but God is alive the Devil
is a defeated Foe and Kim is a Christian
woman and she's not here just to have
content up on adult channels she's not
here just to have that last interview
magazine uh cover if you look at the two
interview magazine covers look at the
one when I was there and look at the one
when I'm not there and that's the reason
why this Tuskegee experiment of such
that's happened to the black community
where they took the fathers out of the
home and the leaders out of the
community and have torn apart the
community now they've seen that's worked
and they're doing that to America
they're attempting they're trying I mean
the interview magazine cover you're
talking about I think is the one where
she was basically semi-naked in front of
the American flag and I I thought
thought that was pretty distasteful
actually
it was about the American dream and I
thought well if that's the American
dream we're all screwed I mean in
America
and I and I agree with that and I I
didn't feel the platform to voice my
opinion because I wanna it's always like
hey this is your kid's mother this year
but it's time with the leaders like I'm
still the priest of that home they they
want to make it this matriarch Society
all that and you know but I am the
priest of this home and God is alive I
am the living Robert Kardashian and I'm
gonna stand up for what God would want
as a Christian and then people say as a
Christian or you're not supposed to
curse you're not supposed to have
righteous indignation but I do you know
Christians had swords also Christians
got guns I tell you that are you sad
that you're no longer together that
you're divorced I had this like you know
of course I'm I'm a divorced and this is
like a a funny thing I thought being
that her name is no longer West
and my name is no longer yay if there
was ever I mean sorry being that her
name is no longer West and my name is
now only yea if we were ever to be
together again what would our name be
kimye
would you like that everything is up to
God and God
has proven to me
many times that it's not about what I
want or what I would like
it says up
to him
on what he sees
fits do you still love Kim
I absolutely love I love her for life
and I'll pray and I will protect oddly
enough I'll actually protect her because
when I call out things that I feel are
wrong that actually is
a form of protection if you feel like
you've gone through a very tumultuous
period but that actually the love
Underneath It All between two people
remains and would you like to get back
together
those thirst traps still be fire
is that do you understand what I said do
you understand that language
you better explain it explain it to me
what do you think those thirst traps
still be fire means can you explain that
to me well with my uh rather
straps still be fire I would imagine it
because he's a brilliant British man I
would imagine it means you still fancy
or what your ex-wife is that right
you know I I would prefer to not be put
on this uh I would never I would prefer
to not be put
on the spot
uh on these kind of questions what I can
say is
uh God is a God is alive and
he places people he placed David in
uh
uh to tend to to God had David tend to
the Sheep knowing that one day he would
prepare him to fight Goliath let me ask
you about someone we haven't mentioned
Vladimir Putin and what he's been doing
in Ukraine what is your view of that
I
do not believe in war
and I believe
that there is ways that America could
have avoided
this war
but
Biden has money Biden has reasons for us
to be at War right now for selfish
reasons and what I would like to do
without giving you too much information
I would like to speak with my political
advisors to give you the exact
uh exact information I'm not gonna hey
watch this one pierce I'm not going to
shoot from the hip on this one
especially talking about war and things
as sensitive as Ukraine and the Russian
war no no you we already got that um the
[ __ ] comment earlier that we could
work on that I feel like is going to be
massively offensive and I really do I
now that one I do apologize to people
that offended earlier in the interview
on that comment maybe we could look at
scrubbing that if we if we if we deem
well actually actually I would say I
would say this it's an uncensored
interview you said something which
you've now wished you hadn't said and
you've apologized I actually think that
says a lot about you right that shows
you've got that ability to be self-aware
to understand when you cross a line you
know
I will say I'm sorry for the people that
I heard with the Defcon the the
confusion that I call I feel like I
called I cause hurt and confusion and
I'm sorry for the families of the people
that had nothing to do with the the
trauma that I had been through and that
I use my platform where you say hurt
people hurt people and I I was hurt and
I want to say that it's wrong to hold an
apology hostage and I gotta let go of
that and free you know free myself of
the trauma and say look I'm just gonna
give it all up to God right now and say
to those families that I heard you know
I really want to give you guys a big hug
and I want to uh I say I'm sorry for
hurting you with my comments and I want
to word it and not a pres and not like a
political way but in a presidential way
which means what I knew a president to
be when I was growing up in a sincere
way you know how people give those kind
of I want to give an apology and you're
like but did you you know what I'm
saying like no it has to be I want to go
to every person's grandmother and
grandfather
and every person's son and daughter aunt
and uncle and give them a hug and say
you know what I've been hurt so my kids
do music you know I don't want them to
step into a treacherous place I wanted
to be better for them than it was for me
so I wanted to sit down and come
together and really work on that what
would that make sense to you pierce you
know what you ate if you simply said
that in your tweet I don't think there
would have been any problem and I'm very
very pleased actually that we've got to
a place where you felt able to say that
and I think it was sincere but we still
have a problem that's my point I get it
I get it but what you've now done you've
now explained the context of the problem
and you also issued a sincere apology to
people who were rightly offended by the
way you phrased what you said so I think
that's a that's a good place to finish
the interview
foreign
to those who are who don't like you
there's people out there that don't like
you I know you said recently that you
were very popular and I think you're the
most honest man in the world last week
I'm a very honest man was that true yeah
I think I'm a very honest man but for
those who don't like you much more
honest than you actually really yeah I'm
pretty honest because I don't think
you're real right yeah I think I'm a
much more honest person in most ways and
most recently why am I not real but
we're not going to get into that let's
finish up the interview go ahead go
ahead go ahead my question was this what
message do you have to people who
can't think of anything worse than you
running again and will be distressed
about it would you come back with all
the experience you've had of being
president would you come back a
different person would you do things a
bit differently
do you believe you can win this war
yes no question you might not only
believe it I know it will happen
we will win he can occupy these towns
and Villages but all of them would be
destroyed because without ruining them
they will not be able to take those
places he's an inspirational leader and
the way the Ukrainian people have come
together in in these in these terrible
times I mean like you say we've never
seen a sovereign nation invaded
by a hostile foreign Nation since World
War II
Cristiano let me start just by asking
you why are you doing this interview
because I think it's the time to say
something
um
and because I like you as simple as that
I don't say that in public I'm
how many times a day do you get told to
tell people to f off all the time like a
dozen times I was at the Scottish
Baptist last night and it was I couldn't
get away from you and of course as I
said before it's the best thing to tell
people yes because when you're fed up
with them you go you know you can say it
won't bleep you oh
don't bother me anymore just
you know what I'm not going to watch
what I say sorry because I don't think
you do either really I think that both
of us I think have the self-confidence
to say you know what stuff this nonsense
uh yeah stuff the fun police is saying
warm my great friend used to say uh
because I think it's just so what it
does it removes all the fun out of life
it makes life a very joyless kind of
experience doesn't it isn't it I don't
know what's going on in the world
everybody's upset for something and no
matter what you say can please everybody
but for me the only person I'm
interested in pleasing is new wife and
I'm struggling with that most of the
time
I I can't play like that because my wife
gets mad when I'm playing she doesn't
like my sense of humor well your wife is
probably thinking I'm gonna get canceled
or something
[Music]
you posted openly about him six seven
Partners at once so is that righteous
I'm hunting him there's no moral view
from me
this is talk TV
[Music]
Mr President for this lady thank you
both very much indeed I want to ask you
first we're five months into the war
into the sixth month now
how are you both doing how are you
coping with this
how are you doing how are you doing
well
if I may say so to be honest I have this
feeling as if it were one day that is
why when it was the sixth day the
seventh day of War since that day I
really have this feeling that all of
this is one very long day
I don't really see the difference
between five months or six months the
only difference is when we feel that at
the battlefield the situation is
stabilized
or we know that at some points in some
positions we are advancing and I keep
thinking about that as you know we are
all human beings and we have to be
strong
sometimes we want to have someone close
to be next to us and that is what you
miss in these moments
yes I miss my children I miss my wife it
is impossible to get used to it
everything else you can get used to
um
these kind of situations they can make
or break your marriage is your marriage
stronger do you think because of what
you've gone through in the last few
months what do you think I should I have
to begin to answer
okay okay
I agree with the theory that marriage
gets stronger with challenges and I
think in our case it would be the same
we have become more interested in each
other I think in our case it will be the
same story
we have got something else to say to
each other
that is why I want this challenge to
make us more united
what do you think about it my answer
wouldn't be different
Mr President when this war started that
awful night back in February you
appeared very soon afterwards and made a
video address which you put out on
social media and I remember watching it
in real time and being very moved by it
and it was really your decision to stay
here in Ukraine and to encourage people
of Ukraine to fight for their country
some leaders might have left what made
you stay
well it couldn't have gone any other way
because the president is a leader of its
people
the people voted for me and the
strengths of our state
this is something that I have already
mentioned the strength of our state
this is consolidation
this is unity of our people all of us
together the government the people the
servicemen people just want it started
they would go to the streets they would
stop tanks other military vehicles so
the government had to stay in the center
of the decision-making processes
it was very important to make sure that
there is no informational chaos because
we cannot say that this intimidation
works because otherwise they would say
that their informational propaganda
actually won that the government would
leave this is what they wanted
is chaos because chaos is the weakness
of the state
this is the weakness of Institutions on
a more serious note the Russians you're
the number one target for them and your
family is the number two target that
must be a constant pressure for all of
you
but it's not really about you thinking
about your family yes in this case the
family is at the center of attention and
yes this is true
these targets still remain for some
people from the Russian Federation
as far as I am concerned I think it is a
given I think that it is a part of this
situation we are in and we are in a
state of War
the first lady for you as a mother
to know that the Russians
are targeting not just your husband as
president but you and your potentially
your children your family
for any mother that that must be a
terrifying thought
yeah
I tried never to think about this
numbers of targets because when you
think in terms of Target number one
target number two
if you think too much into it then you
can become really paranoid and yes I
understand I'm a mother like many other
mothers in Ukraine that is why all
ukrainians are Targets number two and of
course it's an unpleasant feeling I
don't want to think that they want to do
this to our family what your people have
been saying to me I interviewed a father
in butcher whose son was tortured and
murdered by the Russians and he was very
emotional and when I suggested to him
how would you feel if your president did
a deal with Russia he said no no no no
no and I interviewed two young women
whose apartment block was the last
apartment block to be to be hit by a
cruise missile a month ago the same
reaction instant No Deal they hate yes
they hate and it's understandable when
you when they when so many families lost
for example their neighbors their
children
what the deal
so what the result of this deal
could Russia or can Russia give a child
back no that's why we say no
so there are no emotions only one
emotion hate what is your view of
Vladimir Putin the man who is leading
this war
it is difficult to put it into words
it's not possible to understand how one
crooked idea can throw the whole of
mankind into the Medieval ages
I really don't have words and I really
don't want to say anything aloud because
Normal words don't exist to describe
this
president he is your enemy in this war
he's the leader of Russia they've been
doing despicable things to your people
bombing maternity hospitals committing
war crimes no question torturing people
murdering them what is your view your
opinion of Vladimir Putin
thank you
well it's clear and as you have
mentioned he is Enemy Number One in this
war
it seems to me the scariest thing about
it is that he is in fact sane and he
understands what he's doing I'd say
that's the scariest conclusion that I
can make that he understands what he's
doing
he knows how many people he kills
he knows how many people were raped and
by who
and the number of children killed or
deported
therefore
I only understand one thing
the world allowed the situation to
develop
it allowed such a person to emerge
with that ideology and attitude towards
people
the world should understand that this
result this mistake to allow this
situation is the responsibility of the
whole world do you believe he would ever
use a nuclear weapon Putin be honest I
don't know I don't know I don't know
what his aims are I don't know what the
Civilized World allows him to do because
if it shows its weakness he will use
everything
do you believe you can win this war
yes no question yeah yeah
I don't only believe it I know it will
happen
we will win
we already showed the whole world that
he can kill us
but to conquer our people is impossible
how important has Boris Johnson the
British prime minister been to you and
we really needed the attitude and the
relationship between the lead
we have been in contact every other day
I was not only connected through the
bureaucratic way I was able to call him
once a day every other day
when the situation became easier after
the occupation okay they have been in
contact weekly what about America hugely
important they've given billions of
dollars to help your effort but
President Biden hasn't been to Ukraine
yet would you like him to come very much
I
believe this would be a great signal but
a big signal everyone sees Ukraine's
attitude towards the U.S this would be
the highest
first lady is it true that he didn't
tell you that he was going to run for
president
well well he forgot
he forgot you you've got to tell your
wife you're running for president
he understood that probably I wouldn't
have been fond of this idea and that it
would take a couple of hours of very
difficult negotiations with me that is
why probably each day he was thinking
that this is the day that this is the
moment I should tell her you know but he
kept postponing it then it was on TV I
saw his new year's address it was New
Year's night and found out he was
actually running yes
you found out on TV
Mr President I'm really you you
announced it on television before you
told your wife
[Music]
I was not laughing so much so loud
so those who are who don't like you
there's people out there that don't like
you I know you said recently that you
were very popular and I think you said
you were the most honest man in the
world I'm a very honest man was that
true yeah I think I'm a very honest man
but for those who don't like you much
more honest than you actually really
yeah I'm pretty honest because I don't
think you're real right yeah I think I'm
a much more honest person in most ways
and most recently why am I not real but
we're not going to get into that let's
finish up the interview go ahead go
ahead go ahead my question was this what
message do you have to people who
can't think of anything worse than you
running again and will be distressed
about it would you come back with all
the experience you've had but being
president would you come back a
different person would you do things a
bit differently
do you believe you can win this war
yes no question I don't only believe it
I know it will happen
we will win he can occupy these towns
and Villages but all of them would be
destroyed because without ruining them
they will not be able to take those
places he's an inspirational leader and
the way the Ukrainian people have come
together in in these in these terrible
times I mean like you say we've never
seen a sovereign nation invaded by a
hostile foreign Nation since World War
II Cristiano let me start just by asking
you why are you doing this interview
because I think it's the time
say something
and because I like you as simple as that
I don't say that in public
how many times a day do you get told to
tell people to f off all the time like a
dozen times I was at the Scottish
Baptist last night and it was I couldn't
get away from people and of course as I
said before it's the best thing to tell
people yes because when you're fed up
with them you go oh you know you can say
it won't bleep you oh
don't bother me anymore just
you know what I'm not gonna watch what I
say sorry because I don't think you do
either really I think that both of us I
think have the self-confidence to say
you know what stuff this nonsense uh
yeah stuff the fun police is saying well
my great friend used to say uh because I
think it's just so what he does it
removes all the fun out of life it makes
life a very joyless kind of experience
doesn't it I don't know what's going on
in the world everybody's upset for
something and no matter what you say
can't please everybody but for me the
only person I'm interested in pleasing
is my wife and I'm struggling with that
most of the time
I I can't play like that because my wife
gets mad when I'm playing she doesn't
like my sense of humor well your wife is
always thinking I'm gonna get canceled
or something
[Music]
you posted openly about him six seven
Partners at once so is that righteous
I'm holding him there's no moral view
from me
[Music]
well Jordan Peterson joins me now
Jonathan Peterson welcome thank you to
Piers Morgan uncensored my first
question and there will be people
genuinely wanting a simple answer yeah
but there's a bigger answer too who is
Jordan Peterson well I'm a clinical
psychologist and a professor and I'm
doing that on a broader scale now I
suppose and but it's an extension of
what I've done since
1987 really I mean I I taught the same
things I'm teaching although I've
expanded them
all throughout my academic career and my
classes were very popular and and not
popular exactly
they the students found them extremely
useful why have you become so notorious
because I I look at it as I've actually
watched a lot of your lectures I've
listened to hours of you and Joe Rogan
talking about stuff I don't see the
devil that some people try and portray
you as at all and it seems to me the one
thing we may share in common is
certainly not intellectual prowess where
unfortunately I've many yards behind you
but what we do share I think is a lot of
people seem to have drawn an opinion
about us based on either what they've
seen in a tiny clip taken out of context
a lot of the time or what they've been
told to Think About You by other people
yeah well that's some of it I mean I got
tangled up in a political controversy in
Canada I've been tangled up I put my
foot in it to some degree because I
wasn't very happy with what I regarded
as Government overreach in relationship
to who is in possession of my tongue and
I decided a long time ago and really a
long time ago that I was going to say
what I thought and sort of independent
of the outcome you know often people
craft their speech you know I could come
here on your show for example I spent
half an hour thinking well what do I
want out of this show but I don't think
like that I wanted to come here and have
a conversation ultimately what is your
goal what is what is the point of Dr
Jordan Peterson what do you hope to
achieve through what is now huge Global
fame
um I hope to encourage people other than
that I want to see what happens you know
I want to say what I believe to be true
as clearly and
and carefully as I possibly can and I
want to see what happens as a
consequence and what people don't
understand about that in some sense is
your happiness the purpose of your life
is not going to be happiness sometimes
it is
sometimes that will come but there will
be difficult periods in your life and
happiness won't suffice that but what
you can have in your life is an
adventure you can have an adventure
and the truth is the best adventure
there's no doubt about that and there's
a couple of reasons for that one is you
don't know what's going to happen if you
say what you think now I don't mean in
cautiously and I don't mean
provocatively or any more than necessary
you don't know what's going to happen so
that's very adventurous but also if it's
you and your voice then it's your
adventure a weird thing happened uh
about two weeks ago I was on Instagram
something unpop this picture
and it was you with a friend of mine
Cristiano Ronaldo the the Football
Genius greatest player to ever play the
game as far as I'm concerned and you'd
been to see it uh just privately
and he was saying how great it was that
he'd met you and you'd gone there and
all hell broke this he was bombarded
with people saying this is outrageous
Legend over Legacy finished none of
which would have bothered him because
he's heard all this kind of thing before
but the Venom of it was from certain
quarters was so pathetic it seemed to me
so first of all
what were you doing with Cristiano why
why were you there well he invited me to
come and see him and um he had had some
trouble in his life a few months ago and
a friend of his sent him some of my
videos and he said he had watched those
and then he read my book one of my books
and found them very helpful and he
wanted to talk so I went out to his
house and we talked for about two hours
and he showed me all his equipment for
keeping himself in Tip-Top condition and
we talked a bit about his companies and
but mostly we talked about what he
wanted in the future and some of the
obstacles that he's facing while
pursuing that and so we had a strategic
conversation I would say were you in a
way we either the Ted lasso figure in
his life well that's what it felt he
didn't realize he was missing yeah well
I think maybe he did realize that he was
missing it because he seemed to have
found it to some degree in those
lectures and so and I was I I always
like to hear not only what people are up
to but what they want and I one of the
things I loved about my clinical
practice which was very much predicated
on this like well you're miserable let's
say not to say that he was because he
has a good life in many ways but
if you could Envision a path forward out
of your misery let's say to somewhere
better what would that look like and
it's not a question people ask
themselves with enough depth and then
having developed that vision
what are the strategies that might be
put in place to make that more likely
and again not in a manipulative way but
if you had to conduct yourself in the
proper manner to bring about this
desirable end or at least to move
towards it how would you how would you
organize your behavior when someone like
Cristiano who you know we know what the
personal problem was he'd lost a baby
and his partner was incredibly sad for
him and professionally after that a lot
of turmoil as to whether he was going to
stay at his club and so on and so on
um it seemed to me talking to him in the
last couple of days after he saw you
he's in a much better place actually
that's what happens when you hang out or
reprobate like yes but really
interesting to me that so you got and
you and he both got criticized for just
seeing each other
um but actually it was clearly very
helpful too well I hope so that would be
lovely if it was true I couldn't really
um get my head around why so many young
people feel so anxious all the time
compared to when I was young when it
just that wasn't really a big thing
amongst my friendship groups certainly
but I reckon there's two things one
social media the constant bombardment of
other people having a great time or
looking great often of course imagery
and like having to live up to full side
deals but also a conversation I had with
Dr Phil in America where his explanation
for it was that he said you've got to
understand that social media means that
young people now are being bombarded all
day long and all night long with quite
shocking imagery and he gave an example
he said when I was young he said if a
crocodile ate somebody on a golf course
in Florida the chances are I would never
have heard about it it probably wouldn't
have made the national news probably
wouldn't have even made the state news
and I wouldn't have heard about this
incident now it's quite likely that a
video of the crocodile eating this
person would be whipping its way around
social media within half an hour and
young kids will be sharing it
disseminating it and being exposed to
this constant imagery all the time of
quite unsettling and shocking imagery
what do you think of that theory and
that well I think that in itself was
adding to a sense of everything's
terrible well I think it's a corollary
of an information overload Theory right
I mean one of the advantages to having
to having the computational power we
have is that everything is at your
fingertips and the disadvantages that
everything's in your face and by
everything it might be 40 million
pornographic images like that's a lot or
an endless array of tragic scenarios and
really endless and so that's a problem
and the problem the fundamental problem
is how do you handle the fire hose of
information and no one really knows the
answer to that but we should also point
out that it's no wonder that young
people are demoralized and anxious
because we're doing everything we can to
demoralize them and make them anxious so
on the masculine front we we tell young
boys that while the world's a terrible
patriarchal tyranny and all of that
patriarchal tyranny which is the whole
explanation for history has done nothing
but it press and exploit people and
destroy the planet and so that any
manifestation of that masculine impulse
on your part is equivalent to the world
destroying Force when all masculinity
now is branded toxic yeah and I remember
I think that the key moment for me came
when Gillette had always had these very
masculine commercials with the big guy
cuddling a baby or whatever it may be
they suddenly switch gears and did a
campaign where it started with a lot of
metoo imagery and basically the
assumption that all men are awful until
they can prove otherwise and I predicted
in a column this would be a complete
disaster for them and sure enough nine
billion dollars later they did a
screeching U-turn and went back to the
big guy cuddling the babies because
actually two things I think about that
one most men are not awful actually and
so not all the time oh no some better
obviously um some women are pretty awful
no but not most of them but if you try
saying that and not getting canceled um
but I think also this thing that you've
got into trouble about which I don't
understand why that you believe that
most women
probably quite like they're meant to be
strong and confident I don't believe
that all the data shows right clearly
it's about cultural samples and has for
50 years us everywhere anecdotally most
women I know I think would absolutely
agree why is it that you've been so
vilified for suggesting something which
is so palpably true well I think first
of all that annoys narcissistic women no
end and it annoys people who thinks that
think that there are no biological or
cultural limits on how we manifest our
behaviors and also it it frightens a
large number of women because many women
have never had a good relationship with
anyone masculine in their life and so
the notion that they would need to
establish a trusting relationship with a
man especially if he's also in something
approximating a superordinate position
which is much what they might like to
find him maximally attractive also
implies that they're in some sense going
to be under his Sway and if there's no
trust there well that's absolutely
terrible fine and I have some sympathy
for that because there are no shortage
of women out there who've never had a
positive relationship with anyone
masculine and so they're very they're
completely unable to discriminate
between
narcissistic power and compulsion and
confident competence and so because they
can't distinguish that and they're
afraid they put all of that in the same
category which is something like the
Predator category and and that's not
good for them because well as you said
all men aren't Predators all the time
and they need to establish a
relationship with a man what are your
best traits and what are the the worst
traits of Dr Jordan Peterson
well I think that it's been difficult
for me to to optimally regulate my
irritation at times over the last few
years
and I'm trying to get that right to
figure out what the right because a lot
of things that have happened have
outraged me and then I'm not exactly
sure what emotional tone to take as a
consequence of that outrage and that's a
very complicated thing to figure out and
that's been exacerbated that problem by
the fact that I have been my family and
I have been the targets of very
conniving
um and and attacks and underground
attacks and that isn't stopping I mean
another time when your wife was fighting
a deadly cancer yeah
and so was I so yeah yeah so it's very
difficult to regulate your your temper
properly under those circumstances let's
say and so I don't imagine where have
you most improved yourself do you think
as you got older
I get better and better at listening you
know and I'm better and better at
finding my way forward with the words
that I choose and that's just it's just
a continual in some sense incremental
expansion having met me enough for an
hour what would your initial clinical
diagnosis be well you're probably
optimally disagreeable for your for your
profession
you know because you can listen but
you're also not a pushover and that's a
very that's a very fine line right
because if you're too assertive or
aggressive then you get domineering but
if you're not enough then you're a
pushover and the film director Olivia
Wilde is a new movie out which yeah she
says it's based on you this insane man
this pseudo-intellectual hero to the
in-cell community in cell being these
weirdo loner men uh who are despicable
in many ways is that you are you the
intellectual hero to these people
sure why not you know
um
people have been after me for a long
time by because I've been speaking to
disaffected young men you know what a
terrible thing to do that is
I thought the marginalized we're
supposed to have a voice
just making emotional talk about it well
God you know
it's very difficult to understand
how demoralized people are and certainly
many young men are in that category and
you get these casual
insults these these in cells is what do
they mean it's like well these men
they're they don't know how to make
themselves attractive to women who are
very picky and good for them women like
be picky that's that's your gift man
demand high standards from your man fair
enough but all these men who are
alienated it's like
they're Lonesome and and and they don't
know what to do and everyone piles abuse
on them
foreign
[Music]
yeah I think I'm a very honest man for
those who don't like you much more
honest than you actually really yeah I'm
pretty honest because I don't think
you're real right yeah I think I'm a
much more honest person in most ways and
most recently why am I not real but
we're not going to get into that let's
finish up the interview go ahead go
ahead go ahead most question was this
what message do you have to people who
can't think of anything worse than you
running again and will be distressed
about it would you come back with all
the experience you've had but being
president would you come back a
different person would you do things a
bit differently
do you believe you can win this war
yes no question you might not only
believe it I know it will happen
we will win he can occupy these towns
and Villages but all of them would be
destroyed because without ruining them
they will not be able to take those
places he's an inspirational leader and
the way the Ukrainian people have come
together in in these in these terrible
times I mean like you say we've never
seen a sovereign nation invaded by a
hostile foreign Nation since World War
II
Cristiano let me start just by asking
you why are you doing this interview
because I think it's the time to say
something
um
and because I like you as simple as that
but don't say that in public here
how many times a day do you get told to
tell people to f off all the time like a
dozen times I was at the Scottish
Baptist last night and it was I couldn't
get away from people and of course as I
said before it's the best thing to tell
people yes because when you're fed up
with them you go you know you can say it
won't bleep you oh
don't bother me anymore just
you know what I'm not gonna watch what I
say because I don't think you do either
really I think that both of us I think
have the self-confidence to say you know
what stuff this nonsense uh yeah stuff
the fun police the same one my great
friend used to say uh because I think
it's just so what it does it removes all
the fun out of life it makes life a very
joyless kind of experience isn't it I
don't know what's going on in the world
everybody's upset for something and no
matter what you say can please everybody
but for me the only person I'm
interested in pleasing is new wife and
I'm struggling with that most of the
time
I I can't play like that because my wife
gets mad when I'm playing she doesn't
like my sense of humor well your wife is
like thinking I'm gonna get canceled or
something
[Music]
you boasted opening of having six seven
Partners at once so is that righteous I
will take him there's no moral view from
me
this is talk TV
[Music]
Cristiano let me start just by asking
you why are you doing this interview
with me
because I think it's the time
to say something
[Music]
um
and because I like you as simple as that
would I say that in public
well I like you too and I appreciate it
because I think that you've had to
sustain a lot of criticism this year in
particular probably more than any stage
in your career and I think it's time to
set the record straight and to clear up
a few things not least I suspect for the
fans of Manchester United you must be
wondering what the hell's been going on
oh as I as I say many many times the
fans they always I'm always gonna
say good about them they are
um
the most important things in football
you play for them they're always in my
side
I feel that every time when I go when I
walk in the streets the fans coming to
me and they appreciate
what I did what I do for football and
for me it's the most important in
football defense for me is everything
I want to take you back to last year
last summer you're at Juventus
and there's massive speculation about
where you're going to go
and the big rumor is that you're going
to go to Manchester City
so first of all
how close was that to happening
well honestly
um
it was close
it was close is something that they
spoke a lot
and what the others say two weeks ago I
guess that they try
they try hard to have me
but as you know as my history in
Manchester United it's your hearts
you're feeling the way the history that
you did
before
make the difference and of course as
well Sir Alex Ferguson after a few weeks
things weren't going well at Manchester
United the club just wasn't firing and
in the end Ole gun Oscar the manager got
signed and that's within like two months
of you coming back what were you feeling
about what was going on at United and
what did you feel generally about the
club itself and the state that the club
was in compared to when you'd been there
before
to be honest when I I signed for
Manchester United I thought everything
was changed because it's 13 years that I
change
I was in Real Madrid nine years and
three in Juventus and when I arrived I
thought everything will be different you
know the technology the infrastructures
and everything but I was surprised
in a bad way let's say in that way with
little things like even the swimming
pool that the players use the saunas all
these facilities nothing had changed
since you'd left in 2009 nothing changed
surprisingly not only the bull the
jacuzzi even the gym
even some points of Technology the
kitchen
the chefs which as I appreciate lovely
lovely persons they stop in a in a time
which is his it surprised me a lot I
thought I will see different things
different as I mentioned before
technology
infrastructure
but unfortunately we see many
things that I'm used to seeing when I
was
20 21 23 so surprised me a lot when you
look at I mean United have had some of
the best managers in the world follow
Sir Alex Ferguson and they've all been
relative failures compared to other
stages of their careers do you think
that partly that's down to the the
structural element of this that just
isn't the support that top managers need
I don't know what's going on but since
since the saralex Ferguson left I saw
not evolution in the club the progress
was Zero
for example you have a interesting point
that how the club as Manchester United
after suck
Ollie
they buy they bring sport directive
Ralph regnick which is something that
nobody understands this guy is not even
a coach
a bigger club like Manchester United
bring sport directive
surprise not only me but all the worlds
you know well it's a ridiculous decision
wasn't it of course in my opinion it's
you have to be honest if you're not if
you're not even a coach how you're gonna
be the boss of Manchester United it's
something that I should say that
Manchester is not
followed not the right way to reach
successful like other teams like for
example Liverpool or Manchester City
Chelsea they are one step behind or two
because of this kind of mistakes in my
opinion that they should improve and
change probably the
the staff or or the people the
directives or presidents I don't know
who is the
was the problem there but show a lack of
ambition to you when they replaced
oligonna solskar who a lot of fans liked
but he obviously wasn't delivering the
big titles that United wanted and we
used to
but to a point someone like Ralph Randy
I mean I'd never heard of him
and I'm thinking and I'm thinking if as
you heard of him no of course not you've
never heard of this guy nobody and the
people who I speak nobody knew it it was
him suddenly he's did you call him the
boss
of course I I respect we have to call
because he assumed the the job
uh regardless the all the coaches that I
had in my career I call them boss
because if they assume the the job we
have to call in that way but in the end
deep inside me I I never saw him as a
boss so the Runnings come then if it's
your second manager it's not working the
results aren't great you're still
scoring goals regularly for Manchester
United you're about the only one who is
but then you get hit by an awful episode
in your life probably the worst time of
your life
where your partner Georgina she's
pregnant with twins and is actually
giving birth to these two babies
and your baby son doesn't survive
and I don't think I can imagine I have
four kids you have a lot of children
you know you can't imagine a worse thing
to happen than to go a full term of a
pregnancy particularly for the poor
mother in that case but also for you
what was that like for you that that
time in your life is probably the worst
moment that I passed through my life
since my my father died you know when
you have a kid that you expect that
everything will be normal and you have
that uh problem it's it's hard you know
as human being that I am in Georgina why
we had quite difficult moments because
we don't understand why happened to us
was difficult to be honest was was very
very difficult to to understand what's
going what's going on in that in that
period of our life me and my my family
especially Geo that was was tough I mean
such a difficult situation again where
you're mourning the terrible loss of
your little baby boy
but also celebrating the birth of your
beautiful daughter I'll try to explain
sometimes to my family and even my close
friends they say I never felt to be
happy and sad in the same moment yes I
never felt it is hard to explain
um so difficult so difficult it's you
don't know if you cry you don't know if
you smile yes because it's something
that
you don't know how to react how did you
explain it all to your other children
they must have been so confused about in
the beginning do you arrive in home and
the kids start to say where's another
baby where's another of course Cristiano
I had conversation with him
and in the day
and because he's 12 years old he knows
he understand everything and I had a
nice conversation with him we cried
together in his bedroom
and explained and it's kind of
you don't understand you understand but
in the same way it was a little bit
confused it's better to say in that way
yeah and after one week I say you know
let's let's be frontal let's be honest
with the kids let's let's say that's uh
Angel which is the name they go to the
to the heaven I received I receive a
letter from
the queen family as well really yes I do
which is from the queen of South yeah
family yeah and
um surprised me a lot offering their
condolences yes wow unbelievable this is
why I say I respect a lot the English
Community English people uh because
they've been very kind with me and in
that difficult moment on my life
was spectacular the way they treat me me
and my family
and that difficult moments I I should
say straight to the common thing thank
you to the Old English community that
helped me in that moment one of your
biggest critics has been and I'm
surprised about this me too Wayne Rooney
for example who you played with for many
years very successfully and we're good
friends with him and yet all this year
three or four times he's come out and
attacked you in the media because I
don't understand uh you should ask this
question to him but
I don't know
um I don't know why he criticized me so
bad or not he says he says jealous of me
says your behavior is unacceptable
United should sell you you know blah
blah blah blah I mean it was one year
ago or six months ago here in my house
you pick up his kids here and invite
Christian to go his house to play
football I don't I really don't
understand people like that though is it
jealousy as well perhaps that you're
still playing and still in the united
probably because he finished his career
with 30s so I'm still playing higher
level I'm not gonna say that I'm looking
better than him which is true but
but that is inarguable I mean there's no
contest is is hard to listen that kind
of criticize a negative about
people who we play with you for example
getting Neville as well yes I mean Gary
never you blanked him the other day uh
on the pitch and he looked quite upset
actually
um because he obviously likes being your
friend but he's been pretty critical of
you as well when you have people can
have can have his own opinion but they
don't really know what's going on are
they still friends of yours or do you
have a line where they are not my
friends they keep criticize me
negativism every time so I follow I
continue my my trip and I have to catch
up the people who like me
foreign
[Music]
yeah I think I'm a very honest man but
for those who don't like you much more
honest than you actually really yeah I'm
pretty honest because I don't think
you're real right yeah I think I'm a
much more honest person in most ways and
most recently why am I not real but
we're not going to get into that let's
finish up the interview go ahead go
ahead go ahead my question was this what
message do you have to people who
can't think of anything worse than you
running again and will be distressed
about it would you come back with all
the experience you've had of being
president would you come back a
different person would you do things a
bit differently
do you believe you can win this war
yes no question you might not only
believe it I know it will happen
we will win you can occupy these towns
and Villages but all of them would be
destroyed because without ruining them
they will not be able to take those
places he's an inspirational leader and
the way the Ukrainian people have come
together in in these in these terrible
times I mean like you say we've never
seen a sovereign nation invaded
by a hostile foreign Nation since World
War II
Cristiano let me start just by asking
you why are you doing this interview
because I think it's the time to say
something
um
and because I like you it's simple as
that I don't say that in public
how many times a day do you get told to
tell people to f off all the time like a
dozen times I was at the Scottish
Baptist last night and it was I couldn't
get away from people and of course as
I've said before it's the best thing to
tell people yes because when you're fed
up with them you go you know you can say
it won't bleep you oh
don't bother me anymore just
I'm not going to watch what I say sorry
because I don't think you do either
really I think that both of us I think
have the self-confidence to say you know
what stuff this nonsense uh yeah stuff
the fun police the same one my great
friend used to say uh because I think
it's just so what it does it removes all
the fun out of life it makes life a very
joyless kind of experience doesn't it I
don't know what's going on in the world
everybody's upset for something and no
matter what you say can't please
everybody but for me the only person I'm
interested in pleasing his new wife and
I'm struggling with that most of the
time
I I can't play like that because my wife
gets mad when I'm playing she doesn't
like my sense of humor well your wife is
always thinking I'm gonna get canceled
or something
[Music]
you posted openly about him six seven
Partners at once so is that righteous
there's no moral view from me
this is talk TV
[Music]
thank you
which things have annoyed you the most
family issues
um well I want to talk about one in
particular on that which is when you
were late back for the pre-season
training a lot of speculation because
you'd said several weeks before that you
wanted to play Champions League football
and that you were maybe looking for
another option because it didn't look
like United would get to play Let's make
my points for example the preseason
moment and after you mentioned uh
new clubs or interesting for example the
preseason I had a very very bad
witches I don't say nobody the people
who surround me they saw friends and
even my my mom I had some problems in
vacation that my young daughter they
have a little problem they have brown
kids which is she's still conscious
bronchitis yes yes you're a little baby
yes I was in Majorca and holidays and
sister one week in hospital
which is was you know you don't enjoy a
lot and after what had happened so well
exactly and the people make make up
histories that they say that I don't
want to go travel
because they people have to understand
that I'm a human being I'm always going
to be in my side of my family
I'm not negotiate nothing
behind that you understand
and I even have the the lectures of from
the hospital the the feedback of the
health of Bella which is I'm not sure
nobody nobody asked me I have I keep for
me people forget that I'm human human
being that I passed through a difficult
moments
well you must have been worried sick I
mean you I was very worried baby son and
now your baby daughter's in hospital
exactly and you must have been
absolutely directive of
and the president of uh Manchester
United and then
kind of that didn't believe
that something going wrong which is make
me feel bad really yes I am yes I didn't
believe you
they believe you but in the same way
they are there and never this ever gonna
change
the health of my family
for a football never
now or
10 years
behind or forward and it's something
that really hurt me because they doubt
of my words that I struggle especially
Bell and Jill we had one week in
hospital because the Bell have a big
problem
and I didn't go to the preseason because
of that because I didn't I didn't
was allowed to left my family if
something happened
to do it the Precision because I think
it wasn't not fair to left my family for
a pre-season this is why I didn't go it
seemed to me that right from the start
ten Hogg wanted to show you who the boss
was
he dropped you he benched you
he mucked you around
he talked about you in the Press
were you getting that feeling I mean did
you feel that the feeling he always
mentioned to me that I did indeed the
Precision so I should wait for my
opportunity I really understand I should
well okay I understand
but I'm not gonna give you
points but
you don't do it the same sediment from
to every players I'm not going to
mention players but they don't do it the
same way you don't have a good
relationship with them I'm not mean good
relationship the empathy is not it's not
good let's say you think he respects you
I think you don't you don't respect the
way I should deserve but
it is what it is this is why probably
the the game against Tottenham well I
want to come to these two games so
against Manchester City where United got
destroyed
he didn't bring you on
he brought another strike it was but
didn't bring you on
and
I felt insulted on your behalf I was
like surely against Manchester City if
you're losing this badly and you've got
the greatest player of all time sitting
there you at least give him some time
don't you excuses
I see as excuses
um okay you don't put me against
Manchester City because of respect of
your career and you want to put me three
minutes against daughter well that's the
thing so then you then play Tottenham
don't make sense and then he wants to
bring you on with three minutes to go he
was deliberately provoking him nice for
everyone everyone know that
disrespecting you think exactly this is
why I say I don't have respect for him
because they don't show me respect for
me this is why
we we are we are in that situation I
have to be I have to be honest that the
things done going well because of that
because the empathy don't exists and it
keeps it keeps say things for the Press
but the Press
say what they think it's it's it's good
to protect probably him and Manchester
United but I like guys that they don't
like they speak honest they beat frotel
frontal and I'm not negotiate my morals
my morals always will be intact that
seems to have been the pattern of the
way ten Hargis wanted to treat you since
he became manager just constant
attempt to disrespect you I guess
many many points happen
I think in some certain points I think
was strategy from the club for me to
react like that because they wanted you
to leave
probably yes
they're trying to force you out of you
yes not only the coach but the other two
or three guys there around
the club
at the senior executive level yes that I
felt betrayed
and you think they're trying to get rid
of you honestly I shouldn't say that I
don't know but listen I I don't care I'm
always people should listen the truth
yes I feel betrayed and I felt that some
people that don't want me here not only
this year but last year too
many more you guys are at all no really
yes
the owners of the club they listen they
don't the glazes the glazes they don't
they don't care about about the club I
mean
professional uh
sport
as you know this Manchester is a
marketing Club they will get
his money from the marketing
the sports
it's that that don't really care in my
opinion you ever talk to them the glazes
never never not since you've gone back
no they give all the power to the
president the sport directive
a lot of Manchester United fans
are very negative about the glazes they
think they're taking all the money out
and are spending enough on players on
the infrastructure issues he talked
about do you think the fans are right
the funds are they're always right I
think the fans should know the true
should know that
the place we want the best for the club
I want the best of the club this is why
I coming to Manchester United this is
why I love this club
but you have some
things inside the club which is don't
help
to Manchester reach the top level as
City Liverpool and even now Arsenal for
example
which is complicated it's difficult
um
it's hard in my opinion it will be hard
for Manchester to be in the top of the
game
the next two three years do you feel
like you need a fresh challenge
I'd say if it's fresh fresh challenge
but let's say let's see I'm not I cannot
answer right now because my focus is for
the World Cup
but I don't know maybe it's good for
Manchester and berries and probably is
good for me as well
to have a new chapter what is the truth
about other clubs making offers for you
some people have said there were no
offers at all I happened to know that
there was a gigantic one from Saudi
Arabia for example 350 million euros for
two seasons is that okay yes it's true
that's a staggering sum of money yes
which you turned down in that moment yes
I mean that to me says you're not just
about the money I will be honest with
you you don't I didn't have many many
clubs but I have many many offers of the
other clubs which is I didn't change
because I didn't plan to do it but I
have but what the Press keeping saying
the garbage place say that nobody want
me which is completely wrong
and I was happy here to be honest I was
motivated to do it a great season here
but but they continue to repeat nobody
won Cristiano how how they don't want to
play to last year's got 32 goals
with national team I mean that's the
point I don't get because there are
people out there and you see them you
hear them
and they say well he's not the player he
used to be as if somehow at 37 you're
going to be as good as you were at 21.
day by day we're getting old every one
of us you understand it's normal you
have to adapt and I think nobody in this
game
I have this brain that adapts with this
age
I'm not I'm not want to be cocky to say
that I'm the same that when I asked 20
of course no but I'm adopt and I be
smart to know my strength what I'm good
to do and I'm still playing the eye
level and I score goals and I will
continue to score goals Christiana what
a pleasure thank you very much indeed
thank you very much peace thank you
thank you very much
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
yeah I think I'm a very honest man but
to those who don't like you much more
honest than you actually really yeah I'm
pretty honest because I don't think
you're real right yeah I think I'm a
much more honest person in most ways and
most recently why am I not real but
we're not going to get into that let's
finish up the interview go ahead go
ahead go ahead my question was this what
message do